joshua jesse congratulations you guys
have landed in the final round of this
competition
now we're sending you back to your home
forge just to recreate an iconic weapon
from history
that weapon is a locker bar
axe good luck
we'll see you in four days good luck
we're back at my home forge in liverpool
and i'm ready to get started on the lock
of iraq
finishing something that's this big that
i've never done before in such a short
amount of time
is a huge challenge forging everything
by hand has its advantages and
disadvantages the advantage is that you
learn how to move steel pretty quickly
but the disadvantage is that it takes
its toll on you physically
i'll be forged to with today
and i'll be forged to length today gonna
make the best blade i can make
and hopefully it's a ten thousand dollar
axe
i have four days instead of the five
days so that means there's
no time to waste in this contest there's
five pieces to this entire build
so getting everything to mesh together
perfectly that's gonna be the biggest
challenge
i know that when we get to the testing
that i have to
make sure that this thing is as sturdy
and as stout as possible because they
are gonna beat the ever-loving
crap out of this thing this is a war
machine
so i want to make sure that it is a
lightweight blade
if the blade is too heavy i mean that
could be the difference between you know
winning and losing this competition
today i'm going to profile the blade and
get the
bevel on it i also want to get that hook
attached
today too so it's going to be a busy day
i forged out my hook and as i'm grinding
the hook
there's a crack in my hook right down
the middle
i don't want to start damn over again
i can't afford to lose any time today
and
i need to do this again ah i don't have
time to do things twice
i'm running a little behind today so i
don't have time with it too much
i got to kick it up a notch day four
got a lot of hand work that i have to do
a lot of hand sanding
polishing ruling so a lot of small
tedious work today
eight and a half pounds i'm about two
and a half pounds
over what i actually wanted to have it
at
it's a little bit more difficult to
swing and everything like that and
there's a couple of little
tabs that i can cut off the nuts and the
bolts and everything like that that's
coming out for rivets
i shaved off a good pound and it
definitely feels much lighter
i hope that the weight isn't the
determining factor when it comes down to
the
final judgment this challenge was
absolutely a wrecking ball
but i love this blade
[Music]
all right bladesmiths this is the kill
test
now to find out how lethal your weapons
are i will take your locker bars and
deliver killing blows on this big
carcass
joshua you're up first you ready for
this yeah let's do it i don't mind going
first
other than the fact that i might pass
out because of anticipation
but i'm ready to see this thing get to
work
[Music]
all right joshua first up your blade
it's a pork chopper on its thrust
you see the wound channel it creates
such a big deep gash
it's fun to wield it's sharp and most
importantly
it will kill good job thank you all
right jesse your turn you ready
absolutely let's do it i'm really
anxious about this test
it's a little bit heavy hoping that
that's not going to be a determining
factor
i don't know how this is going to go
[Music]
first up your blade has to wait that
every chop into something
want to keep going it wants to keep
going and going and going
to where pretty much took me with it
good chops good cuts and more
importantly
it will kill thank you all right up next
the strength test dave
to test the strength and overall
construction of your weapons
i'll be hooking the shield pulling it
into place and then attacking it with
the blade
all right josh you're up first you ready
oh yeah
[Music]
so first off you took a little bit of
deformation here
pretty much where that edge caught some
of the studs on that shield
but it's still sharp it's really a
nicely built piece got a good look to it
it's easy to wield everything's still
solid
strong axe nicely done thank you all
right jesse your turn you ready
absolutely
all right jesse you can see on your
blade here
where you've taken a pretty good roll
here
and this is sort of a roll and a chip
but
everywhere else on this blade still
sharp nicely done
thank you all right gentlemen next up
the sharpness test
for that i'll give it a dug
this is the sugarcane slice
now to find out how sharp your weapons
are i will take your weapons and deliver
cuts across these
sugarcane bundles joshua first ready for
this let's do it man let's do it
all right joshua you contoured this
shaft here so that when you hold on to
it
you can really tell where the edge is i
really like that
overall sir your weapon is sharp it cuts
all the way through
cleanly it will cut thank you all right
jesse your turn you ready
you betcha it feels like i might be kind
of at a
setback right now just because my edge
seemed like it took more damage
it can come down to the finest details
yeah all right jesse
the blade is heavy it cuts but also you
can feel the weight behind it
crush the rest of it overall sir for
this test
it will cut thank you who's gonna win
this challenge i have no idea
we are neck and neck it's really
anybody's game right now
it's toss-up
josh jesse both of you guys brought in
finale weapons that performed
incredibly well in our tests only one of
you can be the forest and fire champion
and that champion is
josh congratulations you're the force
and fire champion jesse
unfortunately your blade didn't make the
cut
jesse you brought us a fantastic weapon
and this came down to the finest of
details
your weapon took a bit more damage and
your opponent's weapon was a little bit
lighter and easier to control
for those reasons we're letting you go
all right jesse
please surrender your weapon
second place is uh it's not fun but josh
brought a better blade
i gave it my best and i put my best work
out there
i came here to prove to myself that i'm
not uh you know just a
backyard knife maker and i'm ecstatic
that i made it this far
all right josh congratulations you're
the forest and fire champion and that's
a title that comes with a check for
ten thousand dollars good job brother
yeah it's amazing
it's an amazing feeling please present
your blade to the judges
what are you kidding holy crap
i'm a fortune fire champion i'm
i'm speechless
you